do you have remorse for what happened
especially from the perspective of the
employees and the staff
yeah i mean hurting them was sort of the
last
thing that i would ever have wanted to
do
and
in part i mean there was
financial harm um
but
i don't i don't know whether it's more
important or not but
you know it was
taking a place that
was very much like a family to them
um
and it was as if i destroyed it
and so i think that
because we were so much like a family it
was almost as if
like mom went off the deep end and
got together with some
cuckoo abusive guy and and sort of
abandoned them and they didn't know what
was going on and what was happening and
so do you regret lying to them
i regret lying to anybody
in all those circumstances but
i wasn't lying
you know
he made me think that you know
everything was going to be reversed and
okay and anybody that
money was borrowed from they would get
it back you know maybe tenfold and so it
was this weird situation of
having like one foot in his reality
and
potentially believing the things he was
saying or even over time
wanting to believe them more and more
because the alternative was so
um
the alternative was worse the
alternative was like
was increasingly a bigger and bigger
nightmare so so there's this whole
situation where you're constantly giving
them money you're constantly borrowing
borrowing money well this idea that'll
be repaid
like
100 x fold
right kind of like
so sort of like lying to somebody
because you're planning their surprise
party you think like well i'm lying to
somebody but um but it's because
there's a good reason
yeah you know it's sort of that's not a
good example but
but you could have
not made it a surprise party and be like
pull them in onto the planning of the
party
and be honest about
like everything that's happening not in
a negative way but like getting in on
the fact that okay i just need to
give money to this guy
but
we'll get
he is
a super rich person of some kind and
he'll
um
repay
i mean i wish i well
because you're holding on to the first
time i mean that's part of the torture
is that you're isolated
and unable
unable to tell anybody but you're not
unable or he was telling you you're not
allowed to say anything to anybody i
mean you're choosing not to say anything
but it's because of the sort of the
weight of it
because it's embarrassing to sort of
is it embarrassing it's something i mean
what why do you not tell others
you know
what what is that what's what what's
happening to the mind where you don't
tell others
i don't know you're part of why the
story you know everything that happened
is hard to
summarize and talk about
in any concise way is that
so much of it happens in this very slow
slow
slow way and
um
you know people always use the whole
like frog and boiling water example
um so that by the time you realize
you're [ __ ] it's too late
um
and it and it seems
hard to believe or understand to other
people because they see where you are or
where you ended up
and they think well how did you let that
happen and well i don't know i yeah
would i have willingly destroyed my life
and hurt all the people i care about and
you know allowed my mother to get hurt
and
i wouldn't have ever ever willingly done
that so something else must have
happened and that's
that's the part that's difficult to
understand
you